max mayfield is at the very center of
stranger things season four from her
iconic episode four scene to the
explosive finale here's everything you
need to know about that final
confrontation and what it might mean for
season five since the beginning stranger
things has kept a consistent record of
turning things up to 11 for its drama
and compelling emotional beats in
between decimating whatever dares to
step out from the upside down season 4
volume 1 of netflix's award-winning
series accomplished that before a
five-week break that felt like a year on
its own from there though alarms were
raised thanks to threats from the duffer
brothers promising a mad symphony of
chaos for volume two
i
think we're mad fools a lot of us it
turns out they weren't kidding the
mind-flare-sized double-dose of final
episodes hit us with plenty of emotional
gut punches with one devastating wallop
involving fan favorite max mayfield it's
fair to say that for most of this season
sadie sings performance as max has been
at the core of some of its most
heart-wrenching scenes besides putting
kate bush back on the charts it elevated
the character into one of the show's
biggest draws
now when i lie in bed at night
i
pray that something will happen to me
the hope was that she would help save
the day and be rewarded for her troubles
instead volume 2 ended in a bittersweet
victory against vecna in what was easily
one of the show's most powerful scenes
to date seeing any of the stranger
things characters hurt like this would
be a lot to take in but max's condition
at the end of episode 9 is especially
heartbreaking simply due to the time
spent getting to know her this season
between 11 trekking through max's
memories and max finally being honest
about her feelings regarding her
brother's death these emotional beats
allowed us to really connect with her
and see that she had a clear path ahead
that is until the duffer brothers pulled
the rug out from under us and got max
right where vekna wanted max's plan to
use herself as bait quickly turned south
despite eleven piggybacking her way in
to defend her although eleven was only
briefly out of the fight it was long
enough for max to endure a similar fate
as vechna's previous victims making for
an excruciating watch lucas looking on
helplessly as an invisible force snaps
his former flame's limbs was horrifying
but it also played a small part in
rectifying a significant issue in volume
1. after watching him question his
alliances in volume 1 seeing him battle
his former team captain jason and
accepting being outside the norm felt
long overdue this also allows him to be
at max's side during her darkest hour
setting up caleb mclaughlin to flex his
acting muscles and provide some of the
best work we've ever seen from him
culminating in one of the most visually
stunning moments not just of this season
but of the entire series lucas pleading
for max to come back would have turned
on the waterworks regardless but having
both of them be joined by 11 in her
barren and empty realm which we've seen
so many times before amplifies just how
huge the loss is watching max's friends
cry for her together while still apart
is a beautifully bleak sight one that is
revisited when eleven visits max in the
hospital it's like what papa said about
vekma's tactics he takes everything from
his victims everything they are and
everything they ever will be
their memories their abilities the
evidence of this is clear when eleven
makes one last attempt to psychically
link to max but finds nothing vekna
certainly went by the book but it's the
one we see lucas reading we should focus
on before her friends walk into max's
hospital room lucas is reading stephen
king and peter straub's 1984 book the
talisman a dark fantasy novel about a
boy who uses the titular item in an
attempt to save his mother from cancer
the talisman later adapted into a comic
book series takes place in a world of
alternate dimensions inhabited by
parallel individuals or twinners to
those living in ours these twinners can
possess their other selves and jump
between worlds but should one of them
die their doppelganger becomes single
natured this allows them to jump between
realities without needing a duplicate to
inhabit with this page turner in mind
could this hint at what's in store next
season how is vecna still alive after
being shot several times and all burned
up and where is he now might he still
have what remains of max as dr brennan
suggested could max be lost in another
reality herself beyond the upside down
if so a rematch and the fate of the
world could be in the cards for the
final season of stranger things our only
hope is that it can top the most metal
moment in history that was eddie's
rooftop guitar solo better get
practicing 11. check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about stranger things
season 4 are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one